we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a teacher who called
a teacher about the idea of arming
teachers in school
hey david tim here teacher from
pennsylvania look there is no political
will to act on gun legislation so
instead i suggest we just start treating
schools like an airport there you go
dogs high security teams with swat gear
and long guns
guys on the roof treated like an airport
they come in they put their backpack
through a scanner there's metal doors
there's security teams the whole thing
there is no political will to act on gun
legislation let's just treat schools
like a prison and just own that this is
the society that we live in a disgusting
depraved society keep up the great work
work david talk to you soon
now the circumstances here in the united
states are so sick
that i can't tell
whether this teacher is saying this
tongue-in-cheek like saying hey listen
if we can't deal with guns i guess we
just turn the schools into prison-like
circumstances and and i don't know if
he's saying it as in like obviously
that's not a good idea
or if he's genuinely saying
we've got to do that he i i
the circumstances are so depraved that i
don't know if he's being sarcastic or if
he's just giving up and saying we have
no other choice that's exactly what we
have to do
um
wow what a situation
we have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to continue talking about a
number of different things uh we're
going to talk about a juneteenth
controversy we're going to talk about
um a settlement involving twitter and
user data on the bonus show it's been a
big shooting heavy show so we're gonna
take a break from the shooting stuff on
the bonus show but unfortunately i have
way more to talk about tomorrow
including the forthcoming nra convention
so you can sign up for the bonus show at
joinpakman.com
and then otherwise we'll be back
tomorrow and then we've got multiple
streams coming up into the weekend the
nra convention the trump rally in
wyoming which i'm sure will be
completely unhinged so much content over
the next few days
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below